at long last the torch relay begins in
japan
for the olympic games
football star azuza iwashimizu was the
first to carry the flame
10 000 others will take it to every part
of the country
it's shining a light on the progress
made since fukushima was devastated by
an earthquake
tsunami and nuclear disaster 10 years
ago
on the long road to tokyo it's hoped the
relay will generate excitement for the
games
but many are wondering why it's still
happening as the country is still
battling kovid
it would be sad to see the olympics
cancelled but the priority now is to end
the pandemic
we can still postpone it and hold the
games when it's safe again
it could cause another pandemic here
because people from all over the world
are coming here
if it is successful it will symbolize
how we overcame many difficulties
tatsuo sugimoto knows what it's like to
represent japan on the world stage
and compete against the world's greatest
he's worried organizers have run into
too many problems to go ahead
all factors necessary for hosting the
games are facing issues
there are sports that have held
qualifying events while others haven't
when you look at domestic issues in
japan the covered infections are far
from over
and vaccination is not making progress
if the relay goes ahead safely over the
next four months it'll go a long way in
reassuring the public
and signal the end of a dark chapter in
japan's history
andrew chappelle al jazeera